hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu minecraft hero
ich habe gerade schon ein schoko eier
gegessen und mich so ein bisschen hier
präpariert für die folgenden kämpfe ich
will nicht dass die da runterfahren
altert nicht so angezogen ich kann nicht
weg dass mich angezogen
walker hkd tief mich rum ich bewege mich
gerade nicht
ja natürlich ich muss jetzt irgendwie
wieder hier unter druck etappe zweiter
sieg der mich einfach mit sich alter
spaß wieder da war
ihre bilder geräusche jedoch wer das
immer noch fressen dran aber fressen es
mittlerweile nicht auch mal ganz gut
wie viel nahrung ich habe ein bisschen
angst ehrlich gesagt jetzt vor diesem
boss da oben runter gefallen lassen wir
dass zu viele auch wenn die nicht nur
noch wenn ich die alle klatschen würde
es mir einfach drücken wird so toll
jetzt muss der nachbar und laut unter
die ganze kette lande der halt seine
kumpels an
und wo kriege ich den pfeiler ab man da
oben steht jedoch die fahrbahn komplett
ab ist das so die mega nervigste ich
boxte einmal die stimme von tod sterben
so sind die elektrik essenzen ball rollt
gucken
er wusste dieser komische mensch mittels
drei waren die kinder müssen hier direkt
mit der ganzen familie angekommen ist an
der zeit wenn meine zimmertür aufgemacht
wir hätten auch mal bitte sterben gut
eigentlich möchte ich ja xi carl sachen
durchgehen
ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen angst vor ach das ist diese
darkness kenne ich jetzt mal ein paar
sachen einfach mal da rein so was hier
zum beispiel so sachen die irgendwie den
fall nicht
ja ich denke viel großartig andere
sachen sollte ich nicht mehr finden
ich brauche elektriker sense electric
essenzen ist das wichtigste quasi ist
also für mich jetzt irgendwie so wenn
man zauberstäbe machen und so ist doch
cool ich habe gerade echt ein bisschen
angst davor diesem so da oben sind jetzt
erstmal noch welche jedes ist aber
marcel wie kann man so leicht halt
einfach mal boxen
ich hab echt ein bisschen angst vor die
post darum wieder
die das eigentlich mehr wenn ich den
ganz lange gespannt was sind so standard
minecraft frage die ich hier wieder
nicht gekriegt
wo alter ort an dem diamond bullet ja
ich bin jetzt echt ewiglich mal so ein
paar sachen die ich jetzt erst mal
gerade nicht braucht
ich nehme einfach mal alles mit was ich
jetzt hier zu finden kann
noch aufgeholt
sowas ist ja noch alles drin
und oben ist wieder der heftigste blut
und ich traue mich dann klaut boot nahm
an cloud boots und wilnsdorf geklaut wie
gut es gab aber den machen den kamen
doch so hoch springen oder gar nicht ich
nehme jetzt erstmal alles mit was hier
so drittletzte kann danach immer noch
differenzieren was wir nehmen mitnehmen
oder nicht so erstmal alles hier rein
ein rucksack ist auch voll scheiße
rucksack voller stoff
im ostend menschen
ich packe mal ganz kurz ein paar sachen
hier aus die ich nicht brauche
die nehme ich auf jeden fall lacht jetzt
ich muss als wieder hier umsortieren
höre ich da nicht hier noch irgendwie
platz oder so näher ich nicht musik ist
brauche ich eine war ja gut lege ich
mich mal einfach jetzt hier rein wenn
ich jetzt irgendwo sterben nicht direkt
wieder hier auch gut
wann ich möchte die kacke da nicht so
dich möchte ich aber noch
sowas ist ein kuchen
das ist hier noch so drin hier schmeckt
das hier sind die fans dann immer so
komisch gewesen
wir sind brachte bücher ich habe angst
da hinzugehen
ich habe echt angst ich könnte ja
vielleicht mit einbauen
ich könnte mich doch theoretisch einfach
einbauen oder und den dann abschießen
nicht so ich weiß erst mal ganz kurz ein
paar items hier raus oder ich mache
einfach eine kiste offen greifen wir die
besten sachen die ich finden kann und
verziehe mich direkt wieder so was
bräuchte nicht ganz einig dass wir nicht
alles für mein revolver das ganz
natürlich irgendwie auch ne goldene
feder
gold spot ball nicht das brauche ich
nicht kommt zwei brötchen ramatschi
medical medical essentials die bräune
ich diesen scheiße so flint brauche ich
nicht pilz brauche ich nicht 29 fackeln
ja statt blau so ich dass ich das nicht
fremd packen kann
gut das war ein big sword ist ganz gut
damit mut als playboy nicht willst das
macht ja nur finster auf dienstag ist so
wegdrücken
das macht so ein windstoß was soll das
eigentlich dass meine fans kämen so
kacke ist in letzter zeit sonst brauche
ich ein glas wein ich sonst brauche ich
eigentlich alles sonst ich bin echt kurz
davor soll ich jetzt nicht einfach mal
so richtig in gold uploader irgendwas
was ich gerade so womit ich ok bin
irgendwie ich glaube nicht dass uns auch
fast nur einmal was wenn ich dann mal
feiern schieße ich weiß nicht soll ich
sagen da einfach mal hin zu gehen
ich habe angst vor diesem tag boss ist
der boss dan brown backpack das geld das
ich weg für den mord muss doch nicht
erst nach hause laufen
wer der boss ist einfach nicht da oder
versuche ich mich hier gerade mit
irgendeiner anderen festung
ja ich glaub ich versuche mich da wo ich
das letzte mal war das war auch ganz
anders
ja gut egal wo will ich eigentlich nur
eben hier so dinge sind eben nur kurz
existenz suchen gehen dann kommt wieder
so eine kacke wäre man luca so egal
weitergeht
wir laufen jetzt einfach irgendwo blauen
scheißegal wohl aber scheiß egal wo ich
möchte nur irgendwo dahinten ist sogar
schwarz das heißt da war noch keiner
beziehungsweise ich war noch nicht ich
möchte nur irgendwie hexe kinder finden
ich bin bin jetzt level 37 das ganz geil
auf ende
ok tillich habe ich einfach alles
weggeworfen auch gut so mexikaner setzen
erst mal wieder themen die über waskönig
quatschen ich habe jetzt nur das mit dem
youtube dingsbums ach so ja es kam auch
ein thema an meint jemand youtube und
die chance dass man damit geld verdienen
kann
also ich finde das jetzt ehrlich gesagt
nicht so packe ich sage das jetzt nicht
weil ich damit geld verdienen sondern
ich will das kann ich kann mir das nicht
antun diese scheiß facetime ich weiß gar
nicht was mit der los ist in letzter
zeit
ich glaube ich werde meine neue kaufen
so ein bisschen heller hier erstmal dann
mach ich das erst mal so dann mache ich
den fokus noch ein bisschen besser so
die facetime ist gleich viel besser
hätte ja besser beste festgäste sind
hier nicht irgendwo existenzen also der
weiter eine person ja youtube und die
kacke dass man geld verdienen kann ja
auf der einen seite beruft dass da leute
nur internet videos machen und damit so
viel verdienen oder gar kein richtiger
job
mittlerweile ist es doch ein richtiger
job weil ich investiert täglich stunden
in youtube also nicht videos gucken sie
dann schneiden bearbeiten und dann
beschäftigt sich auch mit der materie
wenn man da selbst aktiv ist also man
kann man guckt einmal so statistiken
oder was gefällt den leuten und so
deswegen ist es bewerten von euch auch
immer mega wichtig dass man halt erkennt
was halt bei den leuten was bei euch gut
ankommt bei den zuschauern und wo er
sagte er möchte ich nicht zum beispiel
oder bei den klickzahlen beim gt r
bietet sich so viel geklickt aber es
gibt ein paar leute finden das hat echt
mega witzig deswegen wird die serie
weiter gesetz auch wenn das jetzt nicht
so viele klicks hat weil es auch einfach
spaß macht es halt auch so eine sache es
macht halt megaspaß in der höhe youtube
weil das so gar kein richtiger job
blabla ja aber warum soll
das ist zum beispiel eine tatsache die
ich bei so viele leute nicht verstehen
die sagen einfach ja was willst du
später machen was für mädchen verdienten
jura medizin oder so ähnlich hätte okay
da mach mal
ich will später etwas machen weil es
wissen wenn ihr guten hallo wenn ihr gut
in etwas seid dann könnt ihr mit allem
viel geld verdienen deswegen ich sage
jetzt nicht so ja ich möchte hier und
das und das studieren weil man deswegen
richtig reich werden kann und so gleich
viel verdienen und da kriegt man
firmenwagen unseren tag also darauf zum
beispiel überhaupt keinen bock darauf
zum beispiel überhaupt keinen bock
ich hätte dich wird lieber sagen soja
macht machen das was die spaß macht weil
damit kann man immer ich geld verdienen
wenn man wenn man ihn mit einer länge
was spaß hat dann kann man es ja
eigentlich auch also außer jetzt
minecraft macht mir spaß aber ich bin
nicht so gut darin also dass zum
beispiel das ist schon gelüftet worden
hier alter
deswegen finde ich vielleicht hier so
wenig vielleicht nicht gerade auf dem
weg nach hause ich weiß nicht die tun
uns auf jeden fall schon blutet kef hat
ja mal irgendwie alles richtig gelaufen
sind
ich weiß ja gar nicht unterwegs fast gar
nicht und das hat hier auch gleich ein
ende dieser insel
also ich finde youtube sollte man ist
gut dass die die leute bezahlen weil
deswegen wird der kreativität gefördert
viel mehr leute greift auch die
plattform zurück bei facebook ist es ja
auch so dass einige seiten inhaber leute
typen geld für ihre post bekommen glaube
ich so seien desto oder so die werden ja
von facebook bezahlt dafür dass jeder
aktiv sind wenn man halt den wie also
bei mir ist es nicht so ich weiß nicht
wie man das macht irgendwie ich möchte
dass auch eigentlich gar nicht nutzt
facebook hat mehr so nur spaß
brauchst dir ein paar videos und bei
installateuren nenne ich hoffe es
einfach rund bei ins camp übrigens bei
instagram folgende das ist in der
beschreibung immer verlinkt bei
instagram oder so ist es glaube ich so
gar nicht so bei instagram es nicht mal
mehr wert nicht mehr werbung nur um
wieder auf das thema zurückzukommen ich
find's gut dass youtube die leute
bezahlt weil wir natürlich auch
arbeiterinnen
wenn man sich jetzt vielleicht nicht
unsere videos sondern vielleicht mexiko
schon wenn sich vielleicht nicht unsere
videos sondern die videos von anguckt
wenn sich dann die videos nach man wenn
man sich die videos von sich freddy
morgen oder so anschaue sind namen die
kennt man halt einfach oder oder oder
die polizei nicht mehr so heftig der
investiert nicht mehr so viel zeit
glaube ich aber solche videos die sind
halt echt mega heftig gut produziert und
das halt wichtig dass man solche leute
fördert oder politiker einfach mega mega
gut kommentieren keine mega witzig ist
dass man solche leute einfach forderte
dass alle entfernen
das ist weiß nicht dadurch gewährleistet
ich denke nicht dass ich denke dass nur
die hälfte der youtuber aktiv wäre wenn
man hier mit quasi kein geld verdienen
könnte würde ich jetzt mal so gut
behaupten
das symptom und der sogar noch nicht
mehr gemacht machen jetzt eben tun
wie gesagt wir machen nur einreisen will
keine türme machen wir gehen nur
existenz zu suchen
nein man natürlich immer ein bisschen
kämpfen muss auch dabei sein
tschüss dass meine neue taktik jetzt
übrigens wenn ich dir explodiert das
ding hier gerade das macht der oder
schießt er mich irgendwie ab ja ich
glaube schließlich ab solea bogen golden
user yamanaka universe and we've played
a temporary doch nein das werde ich
nicht benutzten welt soll mega drive
sein und das soll noch gar nicht so
richtig funktioniert die auf dem server
das soll irgendwie das macht ja nur
kaffee dieses riff plate ist halt
wirklich so kacke und komisches wollte
den sie alle machten mit unserem
komisches portal offen singer anderen
welt und das ist negativ
man bleibt doch darunter hoppla da
besser da so ich wollte mal ganz kurz
ein paar sachen einpacken
ja ich meinen rucksack in meinen
rucksack
ich wünsche mir mal was wollt ihr denn
hier paar coole sachen wieder als
granate hügel
alle meinen wenn man das wort inland hat
kann man nicht vergiftet werden lukas
trotzdem vergiftet yaman beste oder muss
ich blocken oder sogar kinder allerdings
eingestellt weil inventar meine fresse
ich habe angst es ist kacke dass ich
dachte ich kann nicht vergiftet werden
wie kaka war das denn gerade ich dachte
ich kann nicht vergiftet werden jetzt
schießt mich der pizza hier auch noch
abstimmt den gibt es ja auch noch
ich habe keine angst man wo ist er
ich hasse nacht hatte es angesteckt
dpa hatte ich erst mal auf hier kann man
kleine minecraft figürchen
pferde horst dank blackberry das heißt
er ist jetzt unser unser kumpel dir eva
möchte ich bis zum serverraum sortieren
jetzt hat man muss da hin
er war nicht hin doch irgendwo vorhin
irgendwann in ordnung irgendwo ist auf
jeden fall schoki
da kam mir egal ich schieße ihn jetzt
einfach ab oder wo ich kann er seine
dingsda zurückschießen musste hin man
rasch dahin vw-stadt pc und verschießt
er darauf nicht ausschließen die opfer
du hast rudolf kann aber vielleicht tut
man ich hasse spinnen sie sich mal gute
sachen drin
guck was bringt mir das jetzt ich hab'
ich bin vergiftet aber ich habe diese
sorry beschwerte land aber bringt mir
nichts jetzt sturm ein
aber ist ja schon mal am liebsten wie
ich das bei tag machen
das ist blöd dass jetzt wieder aber es
ist 19 minuten eh schon
ich guck mal ganz kurz
ach jetzt stützte hier gerade ein
auch ganz gut im ziel wieder ganz gut
irgendwas schön ist dabei
ich weiß nicht wie kämpfer nachher was
wir alles so gesammelt haben elektriker
setzen
ein anderes pferd da habe ich diese
spinnen haste ja man electric essenzen
eine eisenachs tschüss so was da unten
das sind einfach nur spinnen ist das
eklig
solo kann und jetzt ein tolles james
ward land bringt einfach nichts riecht
gut weil ich noch etwas falsch ich mir
die ganze zeit na ja meine lieben
freunde da wir wieder bei 20 minuten
sind würde ich jetzt sage wir sehen uns
bei in der nächsten folge wieder am 23
anders die letzte folge vor der großen
aufnahmestation mit denen und dann wird
es euch gefallen hat wie halt schon in
den videos auf gesagt dann gibt einem
hoch oder daumen runter und dann sehen
wir uns morgen wieder bzw wieder videos